Salve, mi chiamo Sabrina Wallace e i miei genitori facevano entrambi parte della Space Force nel 1969.
Si dà il caso che abbia un bel cristallo di forma simile.
Ora, a molte persone piace dire cose che non necessariamente ci piacciono e che aiutano la gente a capire cose che sono difficili da capire perché, sapete, in questo momento tutti sono impegnati a prepararsi per la guerra dei droni, la guerra elettromagnetica con droni.
L'abbiamo fatto in Iraq e poco prima e sai, il paese entrerà in guerra in un modo o nell'altro.
Che si tratti o meno, sai, della nostra gente o di qualcos'altro, abbiamo una grave carenza di apprendimento negli Stati Uniti.
Indipendentemente dal fatto che sia stato progettato e progettato o meno.
Lascerò che altre persone ne parlino.
Quello che farò oggi è mostrarvi esattamente cosa dovete spiegare ai vostri figli in modo da evitare la rivoluzione del linguaggio orale, sono abbastanza sicuro che sia ciò che si stanno davvero arrabbiando.
E lo faremo con l'istruzione.
Quindi sto iniziando.
Non lo siamo.
Mi chiamo Sabrina Wallace.
Sono figlio di un certo Austin.
E i membri della mia famiglia sono coinvolti in progetti neri, progetti Seps Special Access.
Quindi sono un membro del BAIER e mio nonno è Bernard Heinrichs, e quel nome è Mr..
Ha sposato Helen Harding e Helen Harding è direttamente imparentata con Pius Levi.
Mio padre era Steven Garland Davis.
Mia madre è Lynne Gene Scheer.
Sono entrambi Central Super segreti.
Nel 1969, lavorando a Project Silence, I Am a Modified Child grazie alla Menninger Foundation Experimentation for Human Augmentation.
Ora, tutto ciò significa che ho delle cicatrici che la maggior parte delle persone non ha per l'architettura di John von Neumann.
Non è un'interfaccia cervello-macchina.
È massa corporea.
Questo è impossibile.
E suona ancora cosa?
Sto resistendo lì dentro.
Quindi ecco la lista di nozze dei miei genitori.
Va bene.
Ecco le liste di volo dall'Edgewood Arsenal per il mio prozio.
65/70 Army Chemical, Fort Dietrich.
A dove?
Texas.
New York, Corea del Nord.
Solo uno non è abbastanza buono.
Eleanor Hall È ancora per tutti e tre.
Probabilmente sono qui e ho partecipato ai Mothman Projects e alla costruzione di Vehicles for the Men in Black.
Ora, l'interfaccia per le cicatrici di John von Neumann è proprio qui sotto.
Ne vedo uno lì.
E ovviamente ora sono più grande, ma quello è il tuo cuore.
Ok, quindi questa è un'interfaccia body machine con un database sotterraneo chiamato Next the long, che è IBM.
Quindi, durante la mia lezione di tedesco al liceo, l'ho scritto male.
Nick è caduto sulla destra.
Va bene.
Perché è importante?
Perché se la gente dice cose del genere, farebbe meglio a mostrarti prove, prove attendibili, altrimenti non li ascolterei.
Ok, ecco un po' più di documentazione, e poi andremo avanti e inizieremo con la discussione intellettuale.
Va bene.
Ecco la mia famiglia e Garland.
Mio nonno, Garland Davis, un marine della Seconda Guerra Mondiale.
Fort Meade, NSA.
Mmm hmm.
E prima ha sposato Elizabeth Kraft.
Ma penso che qualcosa con il DNA non funzionasse.
Quindi ha sposato mia madre.
Zia.
Va bene.
Quindi hai lavorato per un'azienda che era costituita dai miei genitori e dal mio prozio.
Oh, scusa.
Ho dimenticato una cosa.
Mio zio, il mio prozio è dove vivo.
Quindi lui è.
È sempre stato una delle mie persone preferite.
È un uomo molto gentile.
Oh, andiamo con.
Questa volta avevo tutto a portata di mano.
Va bene.
Oh.
Così meridionale.
Quindi ho una storia completamente diversa da quella dei miei genitori.
Non mi è mai stato detto niente.
Niente.
Quindi sono cresciuto e lo volevo.
E mi hanno detto che non esisteva niente tranne quello che si poteva vedere.
E volevo sapere cos'è tutta questa roba elettromagnetica?
Sono cresciuto negli anni ottanta, negli anni novanta.
Sono nato nel 1979, e se parlavi dell'aura, tutti ti mettevano in un angolo e ti chiedevano di unirti al loro gruppo di lettori.
E stavo sempre seduta lì, come se ti rendessi conto che è una parte del corpo.
E mi piace, No, sei stupido.
Devi avere una religione.
Non ho mai capito cosa fossi.
Non sapevo perché le persone si comportassero in modo così stupido, ad esempio perché mentiresti su una parte del corpo?
Eppure i miei genitori erano scoiattoli segreti.
Sono quattro livelli di applicazione della legge al di sopra di tutto ciò che i civili vedono.
E sono le ex.
L'élite segreta.
Cosa?
È un servizio segreto d'élite.
E questo è praticamente tutto.
Una volta lì, si tratta di forze dell'ordine segrete.
In questo momento, devi salire di un altro livello.
Ok, ora devo salire di un altro livello.
Sono seri.
Sì, posso salire di un altro livello.
Giusto.
Quindi sono andato avanti e sono andato a lavorare per un'azienda di Louisville, nel Kentucky, chiamata High Speed Access.
Ed è stato allora che mi hanno inviato i miei documenti per lavorare per farli vedere proprio lì.
Hanno appena assorbito il sudore dei loro vecchi adulti.
Questo è il ritorno nello spazio per noi.
Il vero backend di questo paese.
Sono stato uno dei due tecnici a collegare lo stato del Wisconsin dalla connessione remota alla banda larga.
Quindi sono molto chiaro.
L-3 Harris o C 24, tutti i diversi modi in cui gestiamo con ogni tipo di intelligenza, il programma PRISM della NSA, il tutto compresi i pacchetti di data gram.
L'ingegneria di rete non è la stessa dell'installazione di un modem via cavo.
Devo lavorare con il tecnico dell'impianto e l'ingegnere dell'impianto.
Non c'è nessuno che assuma un impianto in quel settore.
E non c'era nessuno che mi assumesse in quella posizione oltre a quello che faccio io.
Sì, avevo 19 anni.
Quindi per il turismo internazionale, in modo che mentre continuo qui la gente non abbia davvero niente da dirmi perché sono esattamente dove ti dico che sono.
Corpo intero.
Scusate il mio piede sporco.
Bene, allora, sorella.
Vediamo.
Ho chiesto servizi tecnici, una rete universitaria professionale monitorata da UW Whitewater, vari pacchetti software, tra cui un sacco di oro nella rete Maps, HP vintage, open view in brevi interazioni con snort.
Le operazioni del secondo turno includono l'elaborazione di database utilizzando PeopleSoft, otto router e switch di codifica aggiornati, collaborazione con Visio per creare una mappa in fibra del campus, formazione avviata.
Per una cosa semplice, ovviamente, si tratta di un intero stato come un piccolo pezzo.
Quando sono andato al centro operativo di rete, Louisville, o volevo costruirmi uno di quei consulenti di rete presso Omni Resources a Green Bay.
Problemi con il sistema operativo, problemi con gli studenti, conflitti con Shock West.
L'azienda proprietaria ha sviluppato software, ha collaborato con Cisco Fixed Firewall, Program Assistant to Department of Corrections Wales, Wisconsin, ha installato e implementato il programma di tracciamento interno, Facility Maintenance Department della Ethan Allen School for Boys Sviluppa database e accedi e fornisce indicazioni per l'implementazione Oracle Risoluzione dei problemi di rete e desktop all'interno dei reparti e un grosso lavoro.
Dall'ottobre 1999 al 22 maggio, Charter Communications ha mantenuto un aggiornamento e ha insegnato e risolto i problemi della rete ISP composta da Cisco tre Kong Comm 21 e Bay Networks aveva cinque rack installati e lo aveva in stagione.
La direzione di Colin Cable, responsabile del rapporto settimanale e mensile, dell'utilizzo della larghezza di banda e dei circuiti, dei test, dei modem via cavo restituiti, dei problemi di garanzia o di ridistribuzione, della copertura leggera, dell'area di responsabilità per oltre 12.000 clienti, ha installato e mantenuto i server Cisco AC 5300 per sette pool separati, ha monitorato la larghezza di banda nei router Cisco 7200 configurati con aggiornamenti per 9000 clienti e gestisce le relazioni tra operatore via cavo e tecnici a Plainfield, Illinois, mentre forma il nuovo personale in ambito tecnico e incarichi amministrativi nel gennaio 2001.
Dai un'occhiata all'elenco dei software e questo è qualcosa che è stato disabilitato definitivamente nel 2004 per essere stata depressa dal suo stesso governo.
Per chiudere la porta a questo ho detto Sei ancora telepatico seguendo i progetti?
Sai, forse no, ma ormai sarà divertente.
Quindi dove andremo da qui a fare una passeggiata nella realtà di oggi nel 2022.
E prima, avremo una piccola lezione dal passato.
Nel mio lavoro quando lavoravo alla UW Whitewater.
Ha un enorme magnete sotto di sé in un satellite fisso in orbita terrestre bassa sopra di lei.
E durante gli anni settanta, UW Whitewater aveva un sacco di software in circolazione per tutti quei database sotterranei di Nick Furlong, IBM e simili.
Sono sottoterra.
Quindi questo non è un forse, è una certezza.
Ha a che fare con il raffreddamento più di ogni altra cosa.
Quindi, ancora una volta, da bambino, sto crescendo disegnando cose come queste: testavano l'interfaccia cerebrale cerebrale per la telepatia sintetica.
E alla gente è stato mentito da tempo su quella parte elettromagnetica del corpo.
E ora siamo in crisi nel nostro Paese.
Questo è del 1993, ed è così che funzionano i layout Bluetooth di Zigbee.
Ecco che aspetto hanno.
E questo è esattamente il modo in cui si comportano anche nelle telecomunicazioni.
E ho intenzione di mostrarmi tutto questo.
Ma vorrei sottolineare che stavano testando sui bambini.
Sì, è quello che fa il nostro governo.
I genitori, i miei genitori, ti consegnano e basta.
Questo è il loro lavoro.
È un dispiegamento segreto per Synchronous.
No.
Scusate, gente.
No, torno su questo punto nello stesso modo.
Quindi questo viaggio per me è iniziato proprio lì, quando ero un bambino, con dei problemi legati all'uso dello scanner, e in realtà mi limitavo ad avere il controllo di tutta la mia fisiologia invece di ascoltare le persone intorno a me che mi raccontavano una storia che mi raccontava come evitarmi di sentire solo il mio corpo.
E crescendo dal 1979, l'ho sempre trovato bizzarro, insolito, ma non lo sapevo.
Non avevo capito che il fulcro della sorveglianza fossero i biofilm umani.
E una volta fatto, non andava bene.
E la mia famiglia mi ha fatto andare via per quasi un decennio perché Perch non mi era mai permesso dire niente.
Chris Sono gli anni autunnali.
Nel 2019, ho avuto un incontro con una ragazza inglese chiamata Ambulance, e al telefono il ragazzo dell'ambulanza mi ha detto: Portatela all'eliporto, portatela al lodge, portatela alla fattoria.
Ora sono perfettamente salvato dal governo.
Era la prima volta che chiamavo un'ambulanza.
Non ero preparato per questo.
E poi ho capito che l'esercito mi stava guardando.
E poi ho saputo di un errore commesso dalla nostra Defense Intelligence Agency tramite i miei genitori.
Non proprio.
Lavoro qui per Charter, ma sono in grado di mettere in campo il radar e tutti questi altri segnali elettromagnetici.
Questo è naturale.
Il cane reagisce nello stesso modo in cui reagisco io.
Non lo diciamo alla gente a meno che tu non faccia parte del Corpo dei Marines per la consapevolezza della situazione.
Ora, Stingray and dirt Bikes utilizza la stessa parte del corpo perché è elettromagnetica.
E nel 1953, il prozio, poi portò a casa un mucchio di foto e droni elettromagnetici e nel 1953 e ancora, mamma e papà nel 1969 lavorando al Progetto Salus, che controlla ogni stato molecolare che si verifica all'interno e all'esterno del corpo umano.
Ora, se guardate le cellule ora, vi diranno la logistica e il movimento e praticamente tutto a livello internazionale per molecola.
E te ne vai, è impossibile.
Questo perché non conoscete il nano Internet of Things, l'Internet of Things industriale e che molti di questi sistemi di interfaccia macchina esistevano nel 1958.
Allora perché non lo dici alla gente?
Voglio dire, Edgewood Arsenal.
Stiamo testando i nostri soldati.
Di nuovo in Vietnam con mio nonno.
Abbiamo droni elettromagnetici nel 1953.
Cosa sta succedendo?
Giusto.
Quindi sono venuta qui in West Virginia e la stranezza con l'ambulanza continua.
Altre stranezze, veicoli che scompaiono.
Quindi vado in libreria e hanno questa domanda.
Oh, stiamo pianificando per la contea.
Sono proprietario di una casa, quindi sono andato avanti e ho iniziato a costruire 60 nuove cose proprio qui in una città di 200 persone.
Erano presi.
Sembra strano.
Eh.
Quindi ho iniziato a fare ricerche su sei pin g lo e, provenendo dall'ingegneria delle reti e dalla sicurezza informatica, è uno dei miei posti preferiti perché mi occupo di ambienti matematici e non è stato così perché ho dovuto subnet il backend delle forze spaziali a quattro indirizzi a quattro punti che sono stati messi in vendita in Florida l'anno scorso da allora.
Davvero interessante.
Ma l'ho capito anche io.
Ad ogni modo, quando eri un ingegnere di rete e stavi studiando per il tuo collaboratore di rete certificato Cisco ai tempi in cui dovevi effettivamente creare sottoreti in binario perché non avevamo abbastanza indirizzi IP.
Quindi sì, leggo matematica binomiale.
In precedenza faceva parte del mio lavoro.
Va bene.
Quindi, quando si tratta di sicurezza informatica, questo è il genere di cose in questa prima parte, totalmente piena di cose noiose, come gli strati laterali e Internet e cose del genere.
Quindi, ancora una volta, quando devi sottoreti e devi isolare i tuoi clienti e sei in debito con certe migliaia di persone che ti inchiodano per una perdita di 300.000 dollari al minuto, all'epoca si tratta di comunicazioni charter.
Allora devi sapere cosa stai facendo e non puoi sbagliarti.
400.000 dollari in un minuto.
Sì, è un po' la pressione a cui sei sottoposto in un lavoro del genere.
Ricorda, ci sono solo due persone in tutto lo stato che possono maneggiare quell'attrezzatura.
Quindi non puoi andare in vacanza.
Fondamentalmente devi fare da babysitter.
Sì.
Quindi sicurezza di rete, 60 Personal Area Network a bassa densità.
E userà macchina a macchina, il che significa che nessun essere umano sarà coinvolto in un veicolo ad hoc.
Nota, ad esempio, ecco un attaccante, ecco un drone.
Ora, ho un paio di problemi.
Prima di tutto, non puoi interrompere quel drone.
La dichiarazione del Pentagono 3000.09 afferma oltre 11 anni fa e puoi trovarla su CSR.
Ad esempio, il Pentagono nel maggio di quest'anno 2022 ha dichiarato che penso che i nostri comandanti sul campo debbano essere in grado di leggere l'apprendimento automatico.
Bene, chiaramente il comandante, il marito, in particolare il comandante, non hanno partecipato al Simposio sull'intelligenza artificiale il 10 settembre 2020.
Se il comandante l'avesse fatto, avrebbe saputo che non si trattava di un sistema nervoso digitale dall'inizio alla fine senza umani coinvolti, cito testualmente, nel Progetto Selous.
Cosa abbiamo imparato sulla consegna dei prodotti?
Date loro il codice.
La piattaforma Salus viene utilizzata per NORTHCOM con aggiornamenti per i fornitori.
Il punto di svolta è che i nuovi prototipi neurali sono in fase di sviluppo e vanno qui.
Allora cosa?
Nuovo prototipo neurale Synchro per cominciare, il G Joint Artificial Intelligence.
Cos'è Fuzing è un'organizzazione fuzing che si concentra sul far arrivare i prodotti alle persone che li utilizzano effettivamente.
Poi si sono chiesti se si trattasse di servizi di rete Amazon ibridi o digitalizzati, e Microsoft e Amazon hanno risposto, oppure mi hanno concesso un contratto governativo.
Va bene.
Poi è diventato più strano per me.
E mentre ascolto, hanno detto servizi di etichettatura dei dati.
E penso: «Questa è un'enorme cura dei dati del database.
E penso a quello che abbiamo scritto io e i clienti fornitori: Questo è il Dipartimento della Difesa.
Quindi per questo puoi andare dall'inizio e dice così il team della Jake, intendo la Joint Artificial Intelligence Commission, il loro ruolo è creare l'intelligenza artificiale.
reale e tutti possono e devono implementare l'intelligenza artificiale in tutto ciò che fanno.
Clienti in tutto il Dipartimento della Difesa.
Quali sono i tuoi clienti?
Guardate questo.
Quindi Contrasting Tools fa parte dell'ombrello di Tradewinds e del progetto Maven e cito i condotti caldi che utilizzano sensori intelligenti, Biosensors Wireless Working Group 82.1 5.5 Wireless Sensor Networks Specialized Working Group for the International Standard di elettronica e ingegneria mi scusi, Elettronica ed ingegneria elettrica.
E Project Maven usa Pathfinder e me per guardarti camminare e pensare all'interno della tua casa in tempo reale.
E citiamo il progetto MQ nine Tethered to ground.
Questa è la Direttiva 3000.09 del Dipartimento della Difesa, che affermava ancora una volta, ecco perché il comandante era irritabile perché diceva: non possiamo sentire queste macchine, non possiamo decodificarle per loro natura e non possiamo far passare un segnale.
E cito testualmente: dobbiamo rendere il sistema dell'Air Force di IBM più coeso con tutto il resto.
Creeremo un sistema nervoso digitale dall'inizio alla fine.
Al Dipartimento della Difesa dobbiamo rifare come connettere tutte le piattaforme IBM.
Cosa controllano?
Piattaforme per lesbiche, veicoli autonomi.
Vuoi dire droni autonomi, carri armati, Stryker normali, ogni genere di cose.
Aerei, controllate.
Che ne dici di qualcos'altro?
Assolutamente.
L'Industrial Internet of Things in quel miliardo di persone che hanno veicoli a guida autonoma ed è tutta aria alleata.
Ma pensavi che fosse solo per la parte intelligente che avresti dovuto prendere in considerazione il nuovo metodo di ingegneria RF per salvare la giornata chiamato Green Road.
Non è una nuova fibra specializzata lungo l'interstatale.
Quando vi viene chiesto, potreste usare un po' di luce per spostarci sul versante montuoso dove si trovano i monarchi e il Curtis National Institute of Science and Technology con accesso speciale per il governo, pagare le persone, non è uno scherzo, progetti neri, ricordatevi che non pago 45.000 dollari per un intero sedile da toilette.
No, non lo fanno.
Ma sai una cosa?
Fanno le brutte iridi.
Per avere una pila come questa, devono inserire cinque codici per nascondere dove vanno a finire tutti i soldi, l'allocazione delle risorse, la logistica e le spedizioni, e poi la riassegnazione degli addetti ai progetti di accesso speciale, e poi la riassegnazione di chiunque sia incaricato di sorvegliarli, tracciarli, rintracciarli o il Dipartimento della Difesa in una lista per la modifica dei progetti di accesso speciale.
È fuori controllo ed è tutto open source e puoi leggerlo e cercarlo su Google.
Quindi questo è il nostro problema qui.
Quindi vuoi spiegarmi cosa sono questi biosensori e di cosa stai parlando?
Un drone MQ nove Reaper.
È legato al mio DNA.
Cosa sta succedendo?
E a proposito, chi sono i tuoi clienti?
In realtà.
Sicurezza informatica.
Sì.
Primo simposio sull'intelligenza artificiale.
Hanno detto loro che tutti gli esseri umani sono fuori gioco, quindi dovrei mettere l'accento sul sistema nervoso digitale dall'inizio alla fine per queste piattaforme connesse con gli umani: evitare il processo e il ragionamento, consentire all'attuale manager di utilizzare direttamente le celle di credito della scienza dei dati e...
Sin da quando ero bambino.
Interviste sull'interfaccia macchina.
Database quantistici.
Correlazione tra manager.
Ora perché dovrebbero farlo?
Quindi la nuova rete 60 Personal Area utilizzerà il tuo corpo per instradare i dati.
E prima di pensare, Oh no, ci avrebbero detto che era stato fatto nel 2005.
Ecco cos'è la rete di sensori wireless.
I biosensori sono fondamentalmente permanenti e permanenti dal 2005 e dal 2005 con Zigbee e Bluetooth, che è quello di cui mi lamentavo prima quando l'ho mandato qui, ero solo un bambino.
Perché Zigbee e Bluetooth e questi biosensori hanno esattamente questo aspetto?
Perché è così che funziona.
Gli standard internazionali per l'elettronica e l'ingegneria elettrica utilizzano una rete Wide Body Area Network e 82.1 5.6 Standard elettronici per il gruppo di lavoro wireless Wide Body Area Network 82.1 5.6.
E questi sono i quattro cerchi della loro scrittura tecnica di ciò che sono in grado di fare attraverso il tuo corpo.
E come sempre, sai, non dovremmo avere più paraplegici e tutto il resto.
Possono farti muovere le mani.
Monitorano la densità del tessuto muscolare.
Possono farti parlare.
Loro possono.
E lo fanno adesso.
Monitorano tutte queste cose in modalità wireless.
Com'è possibile Se il tuo corpo ha bisogno di un dispositivo indossabile o sta usando il tuo router o sta usando il tuo switch come in passato o sta usando il tuo router o sta usando qualcos'altro?
Volevo saperlo, quindi ho capito.
Con la nuova sicurezza informatica qui con Stryker, deve lavorare da macchina a macchina, proprio come ha detto il simposio al DIA de.
Il problema è che l'autonomia è un N9 vuoto legato al tuo DNA e quel DNA genera una parte elettromagnetica del corpo.
E nessuno lo sa.
La chiamano aura, la chiamano in un modo o nell'altro.
Oh, sono gli UFO.
Non lo sappiamo.
Sì, lo facciamo.
Puzzole, Raytheon.
Ti ho appena mostrato la foto.
I droni possono lavorare per più di 40 anni, essere pagati davvero, davvero.
Beh.
Ti teniamo all'oscuro.
Sicurezza informatica, militare, sai, sicurezza nazionale.
Oh, sono UFO skunkworks, Raytheon, Lockheed.
Lo sanno tutti.
Sono venditori.
Allora, cos'è tutta questa roba sui registri psichici?
Scienziati.
Sono inerenti al tessuto umano.
Quindi c'era un libro che facevo leggere ai miei studenti quando insegnavo questo argomento da bambino.
Eccola nel 1996.
Questo libro è stato scritto.
Si chiama Psicologia Integrale.
E dentro troverai quello che ho appena detto sulla telepatia, l'empatia, la precognizione e tutto il resto.
È assegnato a determinate aree del cervello.
Quindi quelle reti di sensori sono su scala nanometrica?
Poi lo inseriscono in un software proprietario quando devono scrivere per Zigbee e Bluetooth per quei biosensori permanenti e, sai, 2.1, 5.4, vengono fissati permanentemente sul tuo corpo dove.
Dalle sincronizzazioni a radiofrequenza.
Ce ne sono due.
Estrarranno tutta l'energia elettromagnetica, incluso il potenziamento dei minerali, dal vostro flusso sanguigno biochimico e la trasdurranno perché il campo elettromagnetico che ritenevate inutile non esisteva e tutti si prendevano gioco di voi.
In realtà trasduce qualsiasi cosa elettromagneticamente.
Ora usiamo la radio sintetica.
Questa è una radio definita dal software.
Telepatia sintetica, solo per agitare la pelle.
Un po' trasdotti elettromagneticamente dentro e fuori, usando parti del vostro corpo.
Allora come pensi che stiano?
Dati informatici?
Allo stesso modo.
I biosensori sono veri e propri magneti.
Sono fissi e regolati con la tensione.
Come utilizzare il Wireless Working Group ADA 2.15.5.
E questa è la tua rete di area personale.
Queste sono anche la tua rete di area personale.
Secondo me, come puoi vedere qui, i sei G Maupin potrebbero avere o meno una rete body area per scopi di routing di sicurezza.
Stanno instradando i loro dati attraverso i tessuti e cito uno scambio di informazioni digitali utilizzando la conduttività elettrica del corpo umano come rete di dati (body area network).
Allora perché non abbiamo bisogno di un chip cerebrale?
Perché sei wireless da 6000 anni.
La medicina cinese, i meridiani, i chakra, sono i punti nodali del corpo, la telemetria elettromagnetica.
Quindi i biosensori permanenti sono stati distribuiti a tutti quassù nelle versioni 82.1, 5.4, e dovevano essere permanenti per Zigbee e Bluetooth, e questo è ciò che li fornisce.
E poi il wireless working group meter 2.1, 5.5 si occupa di tutti i diversi tipi di reti, quindi raccoglie determinati sensori solo da determinati enti, apre il percorso più breve, primi protocolli di routing o motivi di sicurezza.
Ma quando li creano con Zigbee e Bluetooth, devono anche selezionare il tipo di tessuto muscolare.
Dal 2008, devono selezionare il calore in modo da non sentire l'odore della morte.
E così ci hanno lavorato fino al 2011, nel 2013.
E ora hanno circa 13 protocolli di routing diversi, ma solo circa tre di essi sono progettati per proteggerti dalle informazioni che ricevi instradando i dati attraverso il tuo corpo, che a tal fine estrae minerali dai globuli rossi.
Ora, è un preavviso minimo fino a quando troppe aziende utilizzano matematicamente quelle statistiche contemporaneamente.
Ed ecco come appare.
Quindi, proprio qui nel nostro piccolo esempio, potresti anche notare che questi due sono di sei, ognuno ha cinque nodi che sporgono da essi, sono stati etichettati proprio qui e uno, due, tre, quattro, cinque.
Quindi per ogni puntino ce ne sono altri cinque e sono tutti accessibili elettromagneticamente attraverso il cloud, commercialmente con Zigbee e Bluetooth, che di nuovo è, sai, 2.1, 5.4, perché se non lo fossero, non potrebbero vendere Zigbee e Bluetooth a muro.
Non avrebbero potuto usare Alexa in quel modo.
Tutte queste cose diverse comunicano con queste reti di sensori e sono tutte gestite da database di intelligenza artificiale e sono tutte interconnesse.
Quindi, se sei wireless e fai parte dello stesso gruppo di lavoro wireless del tuo telefono, che in realtà è, sai, 2.1.
Quindi, in un'ampia rete personale, instradano i loro dati attraverso di te.
Dal 2005 posso scrivere un'app per questo e poi posso giocare con te in questo modo perché queste sono accessibili dal 2005.
Pensi che la gente non abbia avuto abbastanza tempo per comprare telepatia sintetica, dispositivi indossabili?
È tutto scritto.
E se non sapevate che scrivere un'app non è difficile e GitHub la modella con qualcosa chiamato linguaggio di query strutturato, beh, cosa vi chiederebbe di andare al backend di Microsoft, Apache e WordPress e chiedere a tutti voi: Ciao, questo è l'Hadoop dello stile.
Quindi queste persone negli anni novanta prima che venisse lanciato nel 2005, e con queste persone intendo lo scoiattolo segreto dei miei genitori, le forze dell'ordine segrete, tutte queste cose ancora per chi ancora Space Force dal 1969 segnala l'intelligenza ecc.
Ok, quindi hanno una cosa chiamata interfaccia cervello-cervello, una telepatia sintetica, basata sulla frequenza, peer-to-peer.
Sì.
E indossano un casco alla scrivania e possono navigare attraverso i tessuti umani.
Ancora una volta, queste cose vengono monitorate in tempo reale.
Dicci se non era abbastanza grave.
Ti hanno anche accesso a tutti i database di raccolta che vedi elencati qui.
Quindi la TV, tutti i tuoi sensi, tutto il resto, il radar, il Doppler e poi le scatole sporche volano sopra la tua testa e comunicano con il software stingray, scritto per i singoli dipartimenti dello sceriffo, a seconda del tipo di database a cui vogliono abbonarsi.
Quindi alla fine ci sono tre cadaveri che camminano lungo la strada.
Ci sono due cadaveri in una casa.
Questi corpi vengono ora utilizzati dallo stesso conducente perché i loro corpi hanno la massima sicurezza in macchina.
To machine utilizza solo questi criteri e sono elencati se desideri leggere la macchina, imparando a controllare l'ordine.
E poi la chiave per la separazione tra quante volte colpiscono il nodo, per quanto tempo attendono un ritardo di 0,06 secondi.
Ed è lo stesso nella sicurezza informatica per tutto.
Salve.
Arrivederci.
Intermittente.
Aspetta, resta.
E se sapete davvero qualcosa sull'hacking dei dati con pacchetti e non solo sul software defined enterprise cloud, vale a dire e soprattutto sull'utilizzo di software, intendo per esempio per quanto riguarda l'hardware, che scompone l'intero pacchetto fino allo strato fisico dell'indirizzo Mac del vostro corpo.
Questo è il problema in cui ci troviamo.
Ecco perché siamo qui fino al collo.
Sono collegati al loro midollo osseo.
E il modo in cui Cisco McCann alimenta tutto ciò che li circonda nella rete intelligente è quando cammini, balli e quando ti muovi.
E questa è un'altra parte di cui puoi leggere in otto reti, 2.1, 5.5 e wide body area 802.15.6.
Quindi, ancora una volta, il problema in cui ci imbattiamo è che quando ci sono tre corpi che camminano lungo la strada, questi due ora emettono tonnellate di segnali che indicano che ogni nodo ne ha cinque in più.
Ora, tutti questi sensori stanno impazzendo.
Questa persona qui, la macchina seleziona questa persona qui, il DNA, il tuo DNA, il tuo corpo.
Questo è ciò che crea il segnale sicuro che il drone sta usando per propagare il tuo DNA.
Ed è esattamente così che funziona.
Quindi, per impedire a questo drone di sparare qualcosa, devi impedire al tuo DNA di propagarsi.
Perché avrebbero dovuto farlo?
Quindi un'ultima volta.
Se sei abbastanza sfortunato e qualcuno viene colpito con un'arma biologica.
Si tratta della trasduzione elettrica sul gruppo di lavoro wireless aperto di reti Wide Body Area.
Quindi non importa in cosa credi.
E non è mai successo.
Hanno fatto tutto proprio qui.
Eravate entrambi sensitivi.
E poi, quando trasducono esseri umani ed eseguono test veri e propri, ossia ingegneria tissutale wireless e controllo piezoelettrico totale wireless, mitigazione neurale per la modulazione comportamentale.
Abbiamo danni cerebrali.
Intendi aree molto sottili del tuo cervello su scala nanometrica per tenere sotto controllo il tuo comportamento.
Quindi ti mandiamo alle persone e ti diciamo che la terapia cognitivo-comportamentale ti aiuterà in cougar ha bisogno della programmazione dell'intelligenza artificiale.
Sappiamo che se lo ripeti più e più volte, lo farai.
Allora perché non dovrebbero riparare il tuo ambiente epigenetico?
Perché non sono interessati a questo.
Oppure avrebbero parlato di queste cose alla gente molto tempo fa.
Stavano studiando i trasporti e testavano le persone per verificare le loro abilità nel campo della bioinformatica e della genomica.
Una volta che il corpo non è più in grado di trasdurre questi segnali elettromagnetici, così innaturali, c'è troppa energia nel sangue, nelle ossa e nel sistema vascolare.
Alla fine indebolisce le vene, le arterie, la pelle e poi sei nei guai.
Quindi stai facendo finta di perderti nel bosco?
Sei andato sottoterra?
Sto scherzando.
Quindi questo è quello che hanno fatto.
Nessuno ha detto la verità.
Stingray e le forze dell'ordine erano tutte finite nel 1972.
Quindi fui usato dal capo della polizia con il mio cervello o, scusatemi, la mia interfaccia corpo-macchina all'epoca, perché dovevano comunque avere un tavolo da studio con nanolipidi o idrogel in modo da poterlo esaminare e mostrarlo su un monitor.
Ecco cosa sono tutte quelle guardie.
Quindi ora tutti sono tranquilli dal 2005 e sono disponibili in commercio.
E ancora, il nuovo standard per la sicurezza informatica è una rete Wide Body Area che può o meno essere coinvolta in una rete personale che può coinvolgere o meno il tuo iPad e tutto il resto.
La sicurezza informatica è qui, febbraio 2022, per il sei volte ID digitale aperto il routing e le idee digitali create dal tuo telefono.
Proprio così.
Frequenza e residenza di cosa?
Il tuo DNA generato elettromagnetico è accessibile in modalità wireless dal 2005 come parte commerciale del corpo.
Non ti fanno mai sapere che il tuo medico non lo ammetterà.
Imparerai.
Ne parleremo.
E se ci provi.
Ma prenditi gioco di te.
Perché?
Non vuoi il controllo totale e gli umani e averli sui telecomandi per farli fare quello che vuoi?
Nessun libero arbitrio, nessuna capacità di pensare.
Te l'ho detto.
Mitigazione neurale con subtle.
Cosa ancora?
Modifica del comportamento.
Ancora una volta.
Segni vitali, respirazione.
Semplice.
Apparecchio acustico per il monitoraggio del glucosio ACG.
Quali sono gli usi non medici di ciò che ti conficchi nelle ossa?
Perché quando lo fanno, i globuli rossi devono agire secondo il percorso e li estraggono magneticamente, scusami, quei minerali forti sulla mia spalla, direttamente dal tuo flusso sanguigno.
Beh, dati di streaming video, sport per il trasferimento di file, 3D, video, cose dimenticate, monitor.
E poi ancora una volta ti sarà permesso di fare tre cose: applicazioni di intrattenimento, pubbliche relazioni, giochi e social network.
Cominciamo a vedere come il metaverso elettroceutica sia l'Internet of Things, l'Internet of bodies, il cyber Internet of Things.
È tutto legato all'interno del tuo cervello lì, qui.
Quindi, quando ho provato a dire alla gente come vengo dai Blood Projects e tu hai imparato a capire questa parte del corpo e se non inizi a lavorarci sopra, cominci a capirlo.
Questa è una guerra tra droni.
Aspetterai, non lo fai nessuno.
Quindi quello che devi fare è capire che l'unica cosa che hai in questo momento è innanzitutto la fisiologia, che è ammettere che è la parte del corpo.
Lo colpiscono per la totale schiavitù umana e ce l'hanno.
È incredibile che tutto sia stato fatto nel dipartimento di polizia, nei dipartimenti dello sceriffo.
Come ho detto, sono finiti nel 1972, sono in grado di parlare tra loro con telepatia sintetica e con un gruppo di bambini piccoli.
E poi, quando eravamo adolescenti, ecco il resto, nel 2013, quando hanno effettivamente lanciato l'interfaccia del chip cerebrale.
Professionalmente, la gente ancora non lo sa.
Pensano ancora che tu abbia bisogno di un vero chip nel tuo cervello.
Non lo fai.
Basta acquistare una nano antenna con la frequenza giusta per la rete Wide Body Area.
Bastano cento dollari e poi compri un dispositivo indossabile da 200 dollari che genera telepatia sintetico che penetra nei nervi cranici in modo sottile e ti permette di sentire tutti i segnali intorno a te che vengono proiettati su queste reti.
Queste reti sono connesse a tutto ciò che riguarda l'Internet of Things, l'Internet delle cose industriale, il cyber nano internet dei corpi e prendono in giro i vostri corpi Internet con loro.
Ad esempio, come se non conoscessi la specificità, allora devi conoscerla perché poi hanno detto: Oh, ma è solo negli ospedali.
E io dico: No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
È stupido, voglio dire, voglio dire, questo è un progetto ingegneristico.
Perché dovresti lasciarlo solo in ospedale?
Voglio dire, non funzionerebbe nemmeno in questo modo.
È completamente wireless, satellitare, incluso.
Quindi quel drone sceglie il tuo DNA perché quell'MQ nove è legato a te.
Ricorda che l'ho appena fatto notare e me ne vado, ho detto MQ nove.
Dieci settembre 2020.
Artificial Intelligence Pentagon MQ nine Tethered to ground Project Maven Project Pathfinder con rilevamento di oggetti.
Proprio così.
In un'area cognitiva del corpo, le reti stanno diventando così confuse perché usano qualcosa chiamato rete avversaria e ti attaccano.
Perché stanno guardando.
Pensi con quei commenti cognitivi per guardare radar cognitivi che ti osservano mentre pensi in tempo reale.
E si presenta in un vestitino minuscolo e fanno clic su un pulsante.
Hanno avuto un attacco di cuore e un ictus o qualsiasi altra cosa vogliano.
Qualsiasi molecola, qualsiasi stato in cui ci troviamo, è tutto a loro disposizione dal 2005.
Oh, il minimo indispensabile.
I miei genitori hanno subito questa procedura, quindi è nel 1969.
Ogni molecola del pianeta, ovunque.
Allora come siamo arrivati qui?
Come è successo tutto questo?
Nessuna responsabilità mentale, nessuna menzogna, niente.
Prima gliela lasciamo passare liscia.
Stavano sottilmente fulminando.
Molte persone hanno la fibromialgia, ma nessuno lo sapeva.
Ho detto, un tumore è se hai un tumore, ma non riusciamo a trovarlo fisicamente.
È solo che il tuo cervello si comporta come tale, poi si verifica una pseudo crisi epilettica.
Quindi, cavolo, non sappiamo perché tu abbia così tante crisi epilettiche allora.
Lupus, morbo di Lou Gehrig, un sistema immunitario autoimmune: l'80% del sistema immunitario si trova in quella parte invisibile del corpo, nel 40-60% del sistema endocrino.
Ecco perché tutti gli ormoni non possono mai essere sotto controllo.
Continuate a interferire con la trasduzione elettrica della struttura cellulare di base del vostro organo più grande.
Su, gente.
E poi non lo fanno.
malattie.
Oh, non so cosa sia.
Lo fanno.
L'Organizzazione Mondiale della Sanità ha ammesso che il cancro non è la mia storia da raccontare, motivo per cui la lascio aperta.
Quindi molte persone lo hanno già capito con il cancro.
Dicono, Aspetta, sono malato che ora tu voglia che faccia la chemio?
Tipo cosa?
E sì, quindi non Mr.
Endo, ma ora siamo arrivati alla sindrome della morte improvvisa dell'adulto.
Cavolo, non sappiamo perché.
E quando si muovono troppo e l'ossigeno viene trasdotto nei globuli rossi, si dà il caso che i servizi di spedizione di Amazon abbiano troppi radar.
Le aziende normali prestano troppa attenzione alla sicurezza.
Forse è solo un'azienda normale che sta dragando la geologia o la cima di un set di rocce o qualsiasi altra cosa, ora sta prelevando dal tuo corpo per scansionare l'area.
Ancora una volta, fa solo parte di un gruppo di lavoro sui sensori wireless dell'ATO, 2.1, 5.5 e point four.
Ma ora usa il tuo corpo perché sei nella, sai, 2.1, 5.6.
E per i nostri scopi, per questo, invece dello Stryker, quello è un satellite.
Ha bisogno del tuo corpo tra otto o 2,1, 5,6.
Si tratta di sensori permanenti a vita dal 2005 disponibili in commercio.
E il Dipartimento della Difesa ti sta vendendo l'accesso tramite il database usando il nostro stesso censimento e Doppler, calore e luce, dove vivi e con chi parli.
Ecco perché l'unica ragione che mi ha portato qui è stata quando ho capito che la mia contea, la persona vicina a cui vivo, la mia piccola città di 200 abitanti, sta esaminando il mio flusso sanguigno.
È ancora aperto e questo mi ha spaventato a morte.
Ho seguito il link e ho letto quindi a livello nazionale e, ancora una volta, questo è il febbraio 2022 per il digitale.
Ho saltato un geofencing per catturare le persone in modo che non potessero uscire dal loro recinto.
Ma nessuno ti ha detto che sei wireless perché non vogliono darti il telecomando del tuo corpo.
Quindi cosa farai al riguardo quando il radar ti raggiungerà e lei sarà pronta con il suo DNA a ucciderti?
Perché questa è la dichiarazione sulle armi autonome letali che continuavo a leggere in quel libro di testo universitario.
Sì.
Quindi non puoi sentirlo, giusto?
Il tuo corpo non lo sentirà entrare, che si tratti di un drone o di un transdotto.
Eppure questa è una luce sul mio canale, An Odyssey.
È pieno di sopravvissuti alla guerra elettromagnetica, persone come me su cui questa roba è stata testata e poi implementata su scala di governance industriale per la Defense Intelligence Agency, l'NRO o chiunque altro.
Ora dobbiamo capire che tu non hai più tempo perché stanno andando in guerra.
E lo fanno dal 2005.
E ancora una volta, la mia famiglia era nel 1969.
Quindi qui sul mio canale, insegno pratica del biofilm, insegno offensiva e difesa.
La difesa è ottima, perché così ti apri all'interno del tuo campo e impari ad ascoltare e respirare davvero.
Ma la settimana scorsa è arrivata la pratica offensiva del biofilm, e ti suggerisco almeno di osservarla prima di provarla e prima di rifare qualcosa che conosci bene con il tuo corpo e correggere tutte le cose che ti hanno insegnato male in modo che possano accedervi dal telecomando e toglierti il sistema immunitario, perché ciò che accadrà sono le cariche plasmatiche.
E se guardate che 2030 parla di questo, quel plasma si carica.
Sì, è vero.
Parte elettromagnetica del corpo, la sentirai in entrambi i modi.
Ma se hai conoscenze in anticipo, non avrai paura e sarai meglio preparato a osservare il tuo ambiente topologicamente epigeneticamente e a capire davvero le persone che sono complici di tutte queste cose davvero malvagie.
Ti diranno che i tuoi biofilm iniziano a essere reali o non ne parleranno.
E poi se sono coinvolti in circa due terzi, sono coinvolti gli scopi di questo Paese.
Faranno finta che non abbia importanza e che, oh, non possa influire su di me.
Credo che questo sia il centro della rivoluzione.
Stanno cercando il nostro Paese perché i nostri giovani mettono a rischio biologico queste cose e sanno quanto sia facile comprare quei 400 dollari e avere telepatia e influenzare le persone a Hollywood.
Lo fanno da molto tempo.
Bene, ora stanno facendo un ulteriore passo avanti con le tendenze dell'ingegneria tissutale, l'ingrandimento.
E ho detto alle persone che trasformeranno la parte inferiore del tuo braccio in pesci.
Ma poi dicono, Oh, non stiamo insieme.
E così ora è qui.
Ci sono medici che si offrono di cambiare il DNA delle persone e trasformarle in stati animali, ecc.
Sì, sappiamo che è quello in cui ogni giorno gioca un ruolo.
Ok, quindi, primo passo, devi essere onesto sulla tua fisiologia.
Hai una parte del corpo invisibile e tutti lo sanno tranne te.
Questo è un problema.
Perché?
Perché è il tuo corpo che è importante.
Tutto il corpo all'istante.
Ora proietta quel campo.
Sport a vapore.
Era intero.
Diamo un'occhiata alla distorsione che in realtà sembra essere energia elettromagnetica, non è vero?
Senti che arrivano i droni.
Lo sentirai.
Il tuo corpo lo fa naturalmente.
Algore sembra per gli uccelli.
Tutta quella roba Notes Ley Lines.
I militari li usano da molto tempo.
Perché non lo sapevi?
Perché non ti è permesso saperlo?
Fase uno È la parte del tuo corpo.
Fase due: mettiti a posto con Dio.
Preghiera per le persone che sono come una cosa sola.
Gesù.
Ok, beh, quello che vuoi.
Fisiologia.
Prima.
È una parte del corpo e va bene con Dio.
Preghiera affinché le persone rappresentino tutte le forme di amore.
Quindi pratica le religioni, qualunque cosa.
Ok, gli avvisi sono separati.
Che qualunque cosa tu creda è il dovere che ti ama.
Sapere che là fuori c'è qualcosa di più grande di te.
È privato.
Questo è personale.
La tua anima, essere sovrano nella tua pelle.
Super.
Va bene.
Quindi chiunque avesse dei magneti con regolazione della tensione e poi li consegnasse alle forze dell'ordine e alla sorveglianza segreta e niente medici, niente.
Per quanti anni?
Poi all'improvviso, dopo che il progetto dice: «Ascolta, mi dico: Oh mio Dio, siamo davvero nei guai.
Gatti, cani e pesci rossi.
Ed è stato allora che quest'anno, ad aprile, sono diventato davvero chiacchierone.
E dissi, quella puttanella, ecco le tue vene e le tue arterie.
Stanno bene.
Adesso va bene.
Non si impegnano molto, cioè.
Ma tanta fatica.
Questo è.
Osserva attentamente e poi vai a vedere come appare la biosfera quando se lo aspetta completamente.
Contorto.
Condannato.
Non stai premendo il grilletto.
Sarai dannatamente fortunato se riuscirai ad arrivare alla mia porta.
E a proposito, precognizione, ripeto, nel libro che ti ho mostrato, I ragni mangiano con esso.
Allora perché fai ancora finta di non far parte della loro Defense Intelligence Agency?
Le banche dati del Pentagono contengono tutti i vostri sogni e la vostra precognizione è tenuta d'occhio anche perché è nei vostri tessuti.
Ecco perché i ragni lo mangiano.
Stessa cosa con Algore.
È tutto naturale e tutti dicono sempre, Oh, amo stare nella natura.
Perché tutti questi cavi e cose del genere?
E molto presto se ne andranno.
E la maggior parte della gente non sapeva che avevamo tutto questo plasma atomico di macchia e tutto il resto.
L'avevamo nel 1800 e ce l'hanno portata via per 150 anni in modo da poterti rivendere il tuo sistema immunitario e rinchiuderti.
Ora lo hanno fatto, non abbiamo il vostro biocarburante e l'imminente guerra elettromagnetica.
Non sopravviverai.
È così semplice.
Quindi ora hai le tue possibilità e non hai molto tempo.
1953.
Cosa pensi che abbiano adesso?
Tu.
E poi